all right kids I was gonna try to do
this over at Facebook but it kept
crashing and stuff so I'm gonna try to
do it here man
and record a commentary traffic a
quarantine and tear track if you will
for Jay and Silent Bob reboot if it's
not subtle enough you could tell it's
right behind me men ah this is flick
that I love dearly and doing a
commentary track is always a little
nerve-wracking because you're like what
if I forget something what if it doesn't
what if I you know I've only got one
shot at this that's how we used to do
the commentary tricks but now
digital-age man this could be one of
ninety-six commentary tracks for Jay and
Silent Bob reboot it's the very first
one didn't put one on the blue rider of
the DVD some people were like where is
it here it is we're doing it here in
front of you I'm gonna keep recording it
even if this kicks out man which it
might so until that happens you're gonna
be involved you're gonna be here while
we do the commentary track man let's see
I got my smoke look at that face that
says quality caviar Gold Sun snowgoons
our lunar modules there's a bunch of
stuff behind me including cool ass
solemn Bob from Jay and Silent Bob
reboot action figure from the good folks
of diamond there's a soundtrack is cool
shirt from chivor II look at those damn
games you get him on Amazon man Jay and
Silent Bob everywhere okay Jay and
Silent Bob reboot I went on a 67 city
tour through 67 cities three countries
four months
we sold 65,000 tickets it was wonderful
every night you know some people like
you watched it every single night I did
I watch it every night with the audience
some people were like that's how could
you have done that ooh how could you
watch that movie that many times I can
loved that movie this movie took the
place of my broken heart
after the heart attack this movie it
became my heart and so I put everything
into it I understand some guests don't
like it it's kind of like endgame you
have to see a bunch of movies before it
would make absolute sense to end stuff
so if you're not like a clerks or
Mallrats chasing amy Dogma chainsaw Bob
strike back or clerks - or even as a
chimera kind of person you know reboot
dude be like as inscrutable as a
three-year-old making a film which you
know believe was probably one of the
reviews a three-year-old could have made
this [ __ ] this that this flick means
the world to me man because it's
everybody that I love came back and
played in the sandbox with us it had
been a minute and step so I'm gonna
enjoy doing this commentary tracks are
something I've been doing for 25 [ __ ]
years first commentary track we recorded
was for the clerks laserdisc and it was
you know us on the while we were
shooting Mallrats
on the floor I think at Jim Jack's room
recording and commentary on news fell
asleep stuff like that if you've ever
heard that commentary track so I've been
doing this for 25 years and you always
get like worried like well I cover
everything
I'm worried anymore if anything we
missed I'll do another commentary track
this is the first of a series of
quarantine and terror track being that
we're all stuck inside so you know I got
time now to get around some [ __ ] I want
to get around to including a Zack and
Miri Make a Porno
quarantine and Terry Trek which I'll be
doing next week or down the road or as
soon as I can get Mo's microphone on his
in and we could do it together but for
tonight reboots on the menu kids and boy
I could talk about this like crazy so
here you don't have to watch the movie
to play along you just watch a [ __ ]
middle-aged man talking and [ __ ] but if
you want to watch the movie along with
us all you gots to do is go to let's see
Amazon Prime that's for the movie
streaming if you're an Amazon Prime
member prime video they got it you could
watch their it's on iTunes it's on
YouTube right now
Vudu anywhere you watch a movie man but
if you don't want to watch it with us
again I'm recording this for four
SModcast that's what this microphone is
about so in fact let me make sure that I
can hear myself properly mmm you can see
little behind the scenes here you go to
any of those places
spin the movie up or if you just want to
sit here and watch me and listen you
could always watch the commentary track
later on listen to the commentary track
later on when it's up on as an episode
of spawn kiss which it will be next week
all right we're good in headphones but
rolling rolling rolling trying to cup as
many things here at once okay are you
ready kids get your movie queued up to
the very very beginning because we're
about to take I'm gonna give you some
oral a lot of oral some [ __ ] filthy
oral as I talked about Jay and Silent
Bob reboot starring Jason Mewes who
lives around the block he's nearby you
can watch him streaming on his twitch
channel man making Legos playing games
and stuff he played the Jay and Silent
Bob mall brawl game the other day and
it's Jason muses finest hour he's so
wonderful in this flick man there it's
it's a movie that makes fun of sequels
and reboots and remakes while being all
three at the same time slow wiseass of
the movie kids you know it tries to have
its cake and eat it too the bunch of
people were alike it's full of woe jokes
and [ __ ] and well it makes fun of that
too so it tries to accomplish many
things probably succeeds it's none of
them but [ __ ] did I have a good time
touring the movie man it was amazing and
you know as now we're seeing like the
course in the middle of coronavirus the
theatrical distribution our exhibition
is not even happening
first week there's been zero reporting
zero dollars at the box office since
they started reporting it back and
variety so our little model you know
which is fairly no model its we used to
go out and tour the podcasts and we
still will when we're allowed to go back
out reboot we just took out and did kind
of like that the idea was like well
let's record it like I mean let's go out
and tour it like a podcast and so we
would go in show the movie and then
everyone would sit there and watch movie
and I'd watch it with him and I roll
cameras in the back of their heads
because that send people from the movie
clips of themselves like when they come
up on screen the audience like wow this
is gonna be weird this is quietest
feeling of Jay and Silent Bob reboot I
will have ever had particularly at the
very least in the last four months [ __ ]
so it was just bliss man I loved and we
did the tour and real punk rock style I
was meeting Jay for the first half and
then Jays got a kid so he didn't go on
the second half but my kids an adult so
I did go on the second half and when I
was there for every damn show the in
America 65 cities 95 shows sometimes we
did multiple shows per night and I
watched it with the audience and enjoyed
it the audience has been we love it even
more because you know as much as I know
the material they you know we're
laughing at jokes I forgotten I had
included and stuff up it was fantastic
uh you know I've described it as going
to a church every night where I was both
the priest and Jesus at the same time it
was it was I was a celebrant
and I was being celebrated it was really
really nice
so we'll keep doing this in the future
my dreams do this for clerks three I'll
pay for clerks three myself and then
tore it all year long you know pandemic
notwithstanding hopefully when I'll go
through another pandemic but if life
gets back to normal and stuff we go out
and and and meet in groups again like we
used to
then one day I that's following tooth
clerk's to tour just for like a [ __ ]
year straight we only tour this bad boy
this bad boy for four months so like
being able to I could do that standing
in my head it was me and Josh and Liv
in an SUV sometimes J in an SUV driving
from city to city man is so punk rock at
age 49 and we didn't play instruments we
just put up the [ __ ] movie and stuff
so and during that whole time man 67
cities three countries 65,000 tickets we
sold we did mean greats afterwards I
took a lot of pictures of people
everybody came back I was like hi and
give him a big hug and [ __ ] and put my
hands on for the photo and then I Magen
then they left
so I touched many bodies kids I
interacted with a lot of people and
stuff I must be ground zero for [ __ ]
coronavirus because I've been through
the population in a couple countries
right before everything got shut down
thank god we finished that tour right
before the entire world shut down so I
was able to pay back my my equity
investors because we finished our tour
made money so it was great I'm gonna
keep doing this if they let me in the
future I mean meaning the government's
if they open up you know a life the way
it used to be and believe me I'm
bitching is like keep it shut down until
the virus is gone but if ever everything
gets back to normal we get to make
clark's three I'm touring that
[ __ ] just I got toured this
[ __ ] oh it was bliss alright
without further ado folks I don't know
the rules here on on YouTube live but I
mean yeah make sure there's some proper
courage hold on mmm-hmm okay breath of
fresh air if you will take a peak away
you catch a scent before I dive into it
cuz once we start doing the commentary
trick I'm gonna be looking here the
whole time it's tough probably won't be
looking there if this feed gets killed
or you know if I get killed in the
middle of this feed call the police
please
um call my wife to let her know she's
right down the hall but she never comes
here so she wouldn't know but if it dies
it dies if it dies it does and I'm still
keep recording the commentary track
obviously so if you lose me that don't
mean that's you know oh my god well I've
wasted all my time you saw a little bit
of it and then you'll see the rest
when we make it a podcast for SModcast
economy at least you'll hear it okay one
more one more toke of Courage if you
will I don't want to make it a
commercial but snowgoons powered by
caviar gold okay kids
cue up your movie wherever you got it
man wherever you got you're watching it
if you're watching it on Amazon Prime if
thank you if you're watching it on your
home viewing copy of Blu ray we were the
number one Blu ray the week we came out
go figure I was so delighted and then I
was also so surprised people still by a
physical medium man which right about
now everyone's like glad I got my
physical media and [ __ ]
so it's uh it's whatever you're watching
it on or here on YouTube you can rent it
and stuff like that um probably watch it
[ __ ] free to him sure somebody's
uploaded it and stuff Thanks we work
toward okay but wherever it is get it
ready man get it ready we're about to go
spin it up to the zero mark this is
coming from the Kevin Smith that was
just on The Simpsons the other night
ladies and gentlemen
cartoony Kevin Smith we're about to go
just a note before we go sorry about
this beard normally I'm pretty cheap
clean-shaven but as you could see I'm
totally neck bearding it I wanted to
shave but my wife is insisting she wants
to see how far this will go
since we're locked down in quarantine
she's like I want to see your caveman
beard so I'm gonna let her go in as much
as I can till I can see like how much of
a man I really could have been if I
tried in life so this is not to be you
know don't don't both I know I look
disheveled but it's a choice
story of my life okay here we go man
cueing it up to the zero mark and
pressing play here we go
okay the first thing we're gonna see
something I never saw when I was on tour
of this [ __ ] movies Lionsgate logo
read the top Lionsgate good folks that
you know gave us a sparkly vampire
movies man
they released Dogma back in the day at
one point we were lions gays highest
grossing movie Dogma was long before the
twilight's of this world and stuff like
that and The Hunger Games is of this
world Saban films good folks at Saban
films gave us some loot domestically so
domestic rights this logo is an homage
if you will to the opening animation
from clerks
you can almost see all the character
there's been the other movies all the
characters you'll see in reboot it's a
no Maj the Walter Flanagan's artwork he
did the opening animation back in the
day for clerks for the for the logo but
he asked him if you want to do this when
he's like [ __ ] no get a pro so I did
that Liz's the logo Liz - Joe's logo was
there that's our smog colo go and then
the the Armand Kevorkian and and the
good folks that do the effects encore
the company that did our FX our limited
special effects in the movie and also
they did the special effects on like all
the CW shows Armin just went that
together man he's like I got you
something I made you a blunt 'mobile and
with this logo in it so every night I
got to see that play out in front of the
audiences stuff and every night this
shot come up quick stop with the vehicle
approaching man that people would start
applauding it was crazy you know boom
they saw the shoes and them right here
they'd be like I'd start plotting for
Dante was like [ __ ] Rocky Horror
Picture Show there's great Brian
O'Halloran as Dante from clerks I've
been trying to tell that [ __ ] smoker
joke the Jay and Silent Bob [ __ ] smoker
joke for so many years man when we were
at the Lovitz - in battle on and we did
reap Jane saw Bob get old there we had a
sandwich on the menu I begged him to put
on called the Jane saw Bob's [ __ ] smoker
so it took me a while to get here but we
got here man this sequence this whole
sequence you're seen here there's
Jenelle Rawlings and there's dave de
small chin this whole opening sequence
you see here with the SWAT team this
came from the opening of the old clerks
three script and
I realized we were never gonna make that
movie I've started hacking it up for
parts Mallrats too as well so the whole
movie here this opening was supposed to
be the opening of clerks three and then
led into the adventure on that movie
which barely took place at the quickstep
just like clerks too so this movie
barely takes place at the quickstep
either but naturally that don't matter
man we just spent a little time here
that quick stop by the way is not the
quick stop in New Jersey we're in New
Orleans for this movie nor ones as they
say and I don't know who says if
somebody does not the locals and Nate
our production designer built that quick
step for me man you can see a video of
me online seeing it and crying here's
that one of our many callbacks - you
know all our other movies and stuff this
clerks - obviously with J doing the Tuck
and it's a chimeric homage as well
because he's cut you could see a heart
into his bush if you look real closely
and then of course the other guy pops
into the movie look at him wearing a
mask I predicted this virus stuff oh if
only I had that costume mask now for
heaven's sakes got funny Dom Ellis okay
man that shirt that J's wearin is no Maj
to the Walter Flanagan who wore that
Dark Knight Returns shirt forever man I
love that shirt whenever I figure that
Dark Knight Returns image Frank Miller
cover I think of Walt wearing that shirt
that's why J wears that shirt in the
movie his costume if you'll say hey look
as jordan monsanto produced from the
movie a married to Jason Mewes producer
of his job produces his whole life
there's Justin Long of course and Justin
Long is playing his character from Zack
and Miri Make a Porno
the only problem is I never say that so
you know we didn't set it up properly
and in the first cut of the movie you
know he's playing Brandon saying Randy
essentially and he you know has a you
know it's Justin and he's a brilliant
adler so tons of jokes about you know
hungry hungry for for [ __ ] and stuff
because it made sense because he played
a male porn star gay porn star in Zack
Miri Make a Porno however we never say
that in this movie one simple line of
like I used to be a gay porn star
a lawyer and we could have done many of
the jokes but plen I watched a movie as
I was putting it together and I'm like
without the proper set if you don't know
that guy was a gay porn star in another
movie it just seems like we're randomly
having this lawyer just hungry for dick
so it all went away I got two hours of
footage of Justin long just Adlam he's
brilliant a deliverer ad-libbing you
know about how badly he wants to [ __ ]
Joe Manganiello who's in the scene
you'll see him in a second there is is
the bond the the bailiff in the back as
Craig Robinson enters the courtroom as
well so this was uh we should leave this
gigantic courtroom and it's such
production guy that exists in the real
world of course we didn't build that
that's in New Orleans
Justin playing Brandon saying Randy Joe
Manganiello right there playing the you
know the buffest D&D lovin the bailiff
you know in cinema history and the great
Craig Robinson who agreed to come to him
shoot the movie because we were in New
Orleans during Mardi Gras he was like
your junior Mardi Gras
um there that Mardi Gras was helpful in
casting the flick man because it was you
know some people like to go to Mardi
Gras there's Frankie Shawn and so
Frankie and I were in the Holly we'd
pilot together just like Donnell who was
in the opening scene you'll see a lot of
people I've worked with all throughout
this man I used this movie like a
scrapbook man and just kind of like I
don't put everyone I love in it it's
making this movie was like the whole
final five minutes of a big fish where
Albert Finney gets carried through his
life and stuff like that he sees
everybody he ever met and meant
something to him same thing making this
movie every day was somebody knew like
oh my lord man haven't seen you in a
while and here we are playing plus I'm
so delighted I made this movie when I
did and and not years before that is the
best I've ever looked on film in my life
man I'm thinner in this [ __ ]
then I was in clerks so you know I was
delighted
after myself on film at that point and
stuff I was oh heavens been and some
cats when the movie was in trailer form
and coming out they're like you're too
skinny for it to be solid bottom that's
all right
I'd rather be a [ __ ] emaciated Silent
Bob than like where I was and unhealthy
and having damn heart attacks okay so at
this point in the movie this sequence in
the courtroom and whatnot I watched it
every night I found tours I watched the
whole movie and stuff
there was set up in here that I was like
man it's it's gonna be so necessary to
understand why they don't you know own
their names and ownership of their names
you know was such a big thing in the
first draft you this is a booyah Bay's
of many drafts of Jay and Silent Bob
rebooted it like 20 drafts of this
taking from some movies and borrow of
mine like you know opening with clerks
three and and as I changed it you know
some things remain in the draft but
they're like vestigial tails and stuff
like that you know them losing their
names when I first wrote the movie was a
big deal like that's why they gotta go
back to Hollywood stuff ultimately it
didn't need to be that much and it
played nicely into the like you know
later on at the end when Jays like I
leave my name I got a new name and stuff
but it is kind of like a plot line that
just kind of like gets dropped they and
they continue saying they're not who
they are throughout the movie until
finally Jay reveals who he is and stuff
but it didn't become nearly as important
real estate as it was when I was
originally writing this the story line
with the daughter Jay and his dark that
came out of mall rats to the mall rats
to script was all about Brody and his
daughter banner who he references in the
cutscenes and stuff so here this part
where you know the Saban films owns our
names and stuff like that that came very
lack of Layton in the drafts like while
I was right before I went into
production I think is when I was like oh
[ __ ] now you know Saban films is gonna
be the distributor we can make all sorts
of like some on jokes like we made
Miramax jokes back in the day which
opened me up to be able to make like you
power rangers jokes as we didn't stop
those fun but that got added late in the
process what you're gonna see now next
of course excuse me sorry man was
drinking some of this bubbly bit of the
bubbly as Chris Jericho says who's also
in this movie okay so this whole plot
boy you could never call yourself James
saw Bob ever again is like such a sitcom
me thing and thank god that's not what
the whole movie is predicated on in
earlier drafts Jay did not meet his
daughter and stuff so like that didn't
kick in it was just kind of more or less
a straightforward redo of strike back
and then when I was like ooh I'm gonna
give him a long-lost kid and stuff and
that came from Jason Mewes which I'll
talk about later
Oh Jason Lee Brody himself the audience
would go nuts right here and they'd go
nuts when they saw Brody secret set and
when Jason Lee came out the audience
went crazy man guy who owns all the
comic books is right there over Silent
Bob's shoulder man he bar he let us
borrow all the contents to fill up the
store a lot of range of danger are at
work all over man that was meant for
clerks three originally grid man kept
rib man did that for me but Jason Lee
wearing that shirt kind of looks like
his mall rat remember the mall rat sure
it was all blurry image the idea the
shirts stand on his shirt is that we
pull focused on the shirt that he'd been
wearing his whole life and it was always
staying the whole time there's that
stain memorial you saw how high gets the
big shout out method and red or kind of
the more stay at the time of reboot in
terms of like you know we model our old
lives after them and stuff like that as
you see how I just popped out now
I forgot we introduced the three strains
red before that three strange snoogantay
coochies which we also did and berserker
they exist in real and real life caviar
gold makes those trains of we've been
here California Oklahoma a lot of weed
legal stage and going and buy that weed
sila Bob here working with the phone
this was a running gag that like you
know I thought was very amusing to me
where
it's like well in the age of the emoji
he's always wear that emoji right on his
pin on his chest he would love emojis
and so boom it's a lot of that in the
movie this day shooting the scene is our
first day we shot this on February 26 of
20 2019 and Jay went into this day
thinking like oh I you know I'll just
learn my lines in the chair well I'm
getting my hair makeup done
problem is you can't really do that on a
Kevin Smith movie particularly wouldn't
you lead [ __ ] character cuz you've
got tons of dialogue and this is the big
expository scene that set up the whole
[ __ ] movie and stuff so it was a
tough day which should have been
honestly like you know six-hour decks
it's only like three setups even though
it's an 8 page 9 page scene that was a
15-hour day we went over schedule and
stuff and Jay never range of danger
cover by cameraman Jay never missed it
again see that Captain Marvel like over
Jays shoulder man at one point Brody
puts it on the shelf that was our shout
out to Captain Marvel movie Captain
Marvel shouted out mall rats and stuff a
return movie poop shoot a little a
little quick glimpse there it's still
around in our universe and whatnot so in
in this sequence are this scene here I
you know we do a tour all the time we're
on the road me and Jay doing a podcast
called Jay and Silent Bob get old and so
during most of the show is for a good
two-year period like I was constantly
reading this scene from from the flick
long before we shot it to test drive it
on the road with the audience man and so
it's sharpened because of the audience I
love that little Squeakquel joke if we
test drive the scene so many times so I
got to hone it to perfection man all
that dog me and Jay would read it out
loud I would play Brody
obviously he's on the Bob has no
dialogue Jay would play Jay and so I got
to hear what was good what wasn't good
and stuff this Marvel movie line with
him had Brody calling Marvel movies a
triumph
cinema which is varying character for
Brody happened like you know ironically
a month the movie came out a month or
two after Martin Scorsese was talking
about Marvel movies weren't real cinema
so you know our finger was accidentally
right on the pulse man there was some
jokes out left out and stuff you know
like Brody went after not hardcore but
he made a little joke at the expense of
like the other Ghostbusters movie but
then I was like you know what
unnecessary man I don't want term Brody
into like a toxic a tank and [ __ ] like
that but he is Brody and true to his
colors from that we've seen him all rats
and Jay and Silent Bob strike back he
does have a thing or two to say about
pop culture so Brody in this movie is
taking on two roles the one that he had
in Jay and Silent Bob strike back he
introduces the boys to the notion there
is a movie at all you know from the in
the comic book store then they go to
Holden McNeil Holden McNeil fills the
men right here you see Brody's telling
him about Kevin Smith failing upwards
man I hate stupid [ __ ] cut I [ __ ]
hate stupid give us some of their
favorite lines in the movie the idea
there was we weren't gonna have been in
the movie so I was like well Brody's
gonna have to do double time and and so
he's kind of doing two jobs that from
Jay and Silent Bob strike back the one
he did and the one that Ben did but then
Ben wound up joining us later in the end
of the process
I wasn't seen the last thing written for
the movie in the last week of production
was the spoilers coming out the Ben
Affleck scene the Holden McNeil scene so
back here when we were making the movie
on day one didn't know that seam was
gonna exist it didn't know anything
about Ben ever gonna be in the movie and
stuff so Jason doing all the heavy
lifting Jason Lee and he was wonderful
he said he hadn't acted in four years
when we did the scene but you never
would have known it there we are all are
looking at the audience and when this
played every [ __ ] night Oh thousand
fifteen other people like wow just like
oh it's [ __ ] amazing hey [ __ ] I get
to be in the movie I mean I get to be in
the movie as Silent Bob but I get to be
in the movie as me too and as much as I
love playing saw Bob it was way more fun
playing this version of Kevin Smith kind
of the Babylon the Hollywood babble-on
version
of Kevin Smith he's very this and very
expressive and he's kind of dumb at the
same time and stuff which I guess you
know is not me playing characters pretty
much my life but I love this [ __ ]
little gag with the just we were
shooting I kept telling the boom guys I
keep lowering it lowering it and it and
like he was like but if it's low it's in
your face I was like that's the joke
keep doing and his training all of his
training was to keep it up and stuff but
like for the joke keep let it come down
and you could see it was against every
fiber of his being Jason Lee Brody have
been a Dixie cup come on man little
touches like that you know the that's
that's little easter eggs if you will
for all the fan stuff see the Eternity
blocker in the background over Jay
shoulder that's their version of the
Infinity Gauntlet man man man this was
something for years people be like
whenever they do that Jane's not Bob
strike back what's that reference to
there was nothing it was just something
we did for that movie now when people
ask me it's a reference to that scene uh
Jason Lee ladies gentleman and look oh
my god man the the fact of the matter is
there are a couple SNL alumnus in the
flick man and it's so I've been a long
time SNL fan my whole life so you know
getting to work with anybody who's been
on that show is is absolutely huge for
me Molly Shannon I remember she called
the views few offices 1995 Brian Lynch
was making a movie called big helium dog
and he had reached out to see if she'd
been and she called and it was like
12:30 in the morning or something but I
was still in the office working and I
think she just wants to leave a message
but I answered and she was so sweet and
she was like yeah I was just calling to
say like I loved the script but I can't
be in the movie so Wow and I was like Oh
Brian ask him in the movie Mass that's
ambitious years later 25 years later I
got to work with Molly Shannon myself
which is nice because I worked with Will
Ferrell on strike back and hopefully
will it was gonna be in this but we
won't have cut the scenes that will was
seen that will would have been it
this of course
a reference to like there's lots of
references the other movies this is a
reference to my real life at one point
getting tossed off Southwest Airlines
play this sequence played like crazy in
the audience man the during the tour
that when solid Bob lost a bunch of
weight lady aside from like laughing and
[ __ ] like that at vagina and whatnot and
this part they loved the snack pack they
I got applause just for going like vegan
like when he was like he's vegan now and
[ __ ] in the audience ah
depending where you were in the country
was like louder than others in terms of
the vegan aspect of it but everyone was
happy about the reference I was happy
with the wordplay about weight problem
as an old wordsmith myself that was that
was the part of it for me that I kind of
done so working with Molly we worked at
the actual Airport New Orleans New
Orleans was wonderful to us the whole
city the crew base there is fantastic
everyone who worked on this movie
top-notch the police who helped us like
at the airport that night were so
wonderful everybody the extras we had a
bunch of people come out you'll see them
all later on you see some of them here
you'll see more when we'd get to
chronicon later and stuff riding me now
the app that came way late in the drafts
probably about midway through like draft
ten I was like ah let me include like
let me include that and since I was
doing this like Southwest beat and
whatnot and then this whole thing about
like credit card it doesn't have a
credit card and like the boys
overhearing and the stealing credit card
number in this there's the great Ralph
Garman from Hollywood babble-on playing
the heart character uh-oh [ __ ] from
Fletch smokes it away but I'm probably
gonna see it on the screen so much she's
rated [ __ ] a lesson this
happened not to me exactly but I had
used a like a phone card
Ted Underhill that it is there's named
Fletch shadow I've used my sprint card
back in like 1990 at a Garden State
Parkway rest stop and you know I just
punt you punched into the phone
in those days and so somebody watch me
punch it in and then used my phone card
and stuff so ever since then I've always
been like super that's a shout-out to
some [ __ ] happened to me years ago the
great fred armisen who i worked with
another SNL er I worked with very
briefly on cop-out there's the first
time we've gotten to work together since
then and he was lovely all this Drive
and stuff we shot in a parking lot with
green screen behind us so we're not
[ __ ] driving around we're not being
to a really religious park the joints
the three strains of gold here's the
second preference tone which is a setup
we'll need them later on oh my god that
joint was made by Brandon the the prompt
assistant kid who was amazing you know
he read it in the script and one day
brought it in to me in my office he goes
is this kind of it I was like [ __ ] yeah
son we get to smoke that [ __ ] smoking
like a dick so uh it was you know the
over the scene proper was you know
pretty much just about let me said I'm
trying to thank him being like you guys
this character to be fair at Merkin like
through various drafts of the movie
played a bigger role at one point he was
like in earlier drafts he was like the
the what would you call him in Jay and
Silent Bob strike back he was kind of
like well and Holly he was chasing the
boys all throughout the movie and
whatnot the good thing about this flick
at least as the filmmaker is that you
can start storylines and drop them and
move on as long as you had something
else to present in the next minute that
was even more surprising and stuff so we
didn't wind up needing Merkin for the
whole movie there was supposed to be
like Fred returns at one point in the
movie but there's supposed to be another
return of chronicon at the very very end
but we didn't wind up needing it so who
would have required Fred staying another
day and he'd already been there in the
rain I didn't want to make him do it
again so I was like eh man don't worry
about we're good but he was mostly
ad-lib in this day and whatnot he's got
a line when I cut scenes real like you
see me laugh cuz he we didn't include in
the movie but he I'm looking at the box
of the potato tots the hater tots with
the lipstick on and he goes like that's
that's what they look like that's what
tween girls look like
made me laugh so [ __ ] hard part of
the reason I love making movies in
general particularly comedies is you can
be around funny people and get to laugh
for free most people have to pay people
to make them laugh and stuff but when
you're making a comedy you're sitting
down with like some insanely [ __ ]
funny people like Fred it was just a joy
to work with he would just make me laugh
constantly Justin long same [ __ ] way
absolute joy to work with and he just he
does your script and then he ad-libs
five better funnier scripts Seth Rogen
is the absolute same way days you go to
work and you just like I know I'm gonna
laugh so hard that I'm gonna cry it's
they're so [ __ ] funny and people
normally pay for that privilege and
instead like you know we we pay that I
guess we're payin tooks were paying them
as actors but it's it's like feels like
I'm getting a free show every [ __ ]
day so working with Fred and this scene
was an absolute [ __ ] free show and
what was supposed to happen from here
was a montage into driving Steve stark
who did the opening logo cartoon he was
gonna do driving app thing but instead
late in the game after we wrapped the
movie by Bob
Matt Damon was like hey I'm free and
we've been calling the whole movie going
like hey man like his agent is Matt
around so you want to be in strike back
and like we can't find him he's off the
grid and we wrapped the movie and you
know we shot Ben so we got one of them
and so we were like that's cool when we
got back home and also we got a call
from his agent being like Matt's free
and he wants to be in the movie and we
were like oh man there's like nothing
left or someone's gonna have to tell
Matt Damon no but then you know Jennifer
was like why don't you use him in that
scene man like well it wasn't quite that
I was gonna have that driving montage
cartoon and then instead I was like what
if I had Matt come out and just say
stuff to the camera and she's like why
don't you ever think about using his
Loki I was like Loki from dog Lexi died
she's like in a movie I was if you're
[ __ ] right and I reached it out to
Matt and I was like hey man stand and
said play Matt Damon won't play Loki
from Dogma because I'd love to can we
still get the costume I was like it's a
hoodie and a pair of [ __ ] jeans bro
and boom so I wrote that monologue you
know the reference Bourne Identity quite
heavily and use that to get us to
Chicago so instead of a little cartoon
montage the boys driving around in the
you know you know we got another Jane
Silent Bob strike back alumnus got to do
the old Cheech and Chong slash Fast
Times at Ridgemont High we opened the
door and smoke pours out that's
something I was very pleased about
ladies and gentlemen with this movie
it's a true stoners movie when I made
Jay and Silent Bob strike back I was not
yet a STONER when I made this movie I've
been dyed-in-the-wool stoner for like 10
years ever since I started smoking weed
with Seth Rogen on the last day of when
we were done with Zack and Miri Make a
Porno in the editing room so I saw be
real put up some kind of like a quiz
thing said who's the bigger stoner Seth
Rogen or Kevin spent I'm a smoke more
weed than Seth I don't know but I gotta
give it to him he's the one that led me
down the path man he was he was my qui
Gon Jinn if you will so this sequence
right here man obviously not Chicago
were in New Orleans but we're back in a
movies ladies and gentlemen so we had a
movies in Dogma
we had movies in Jay and Silent Bob
strike back movies you know clerks to
was where movies were focused uh uh
where it was set the membership card
makes a return right there and the nails
lighter and stuff all items from
previous movies so uh you know going
back to movies was a big deal and Nate
and his team of artists kind of did like
today's version of movies you know so
you'll see lots of repeating graphics
and stuff like that
Dave Mandel who will see outside in a
second drinking his coffee he did that
and Jay and Silent Bob strike back as
the boys get on the bus
Dave sitting there were two coffees
coffees double fisting them and stuff so
he came back did first in front of
movies this time around this is a fun
little bit where you know Fred gets
caught with weed although they're in
Illinois so probably wouldn't even
matter anymore weed has gone legal but
it's joke played very well audiences
absolutely love this and Fred was so
funny Dave Mandel who's worked for SNL
for years he did veep for the last few
seasons he was the one that said bring
him up to the window and pound and they
just don't you know hear him and stuff
yeah Kate Micucci ah I love Kate man she
was amazing she came in and rocked it
with it would have
he's putting the mood for and she I
remember like she was having such a hard
time with the knife and she was like I'm
wrote in the sand Isaac oh my god you
made the scene with that movie [ __ ] you
[ __ ] with the knife I wanted stuff
this was a fun little bit for me because
I you know I get to play with the
veganism thing again
and the movies are always the snapshot
of where I am in my life at that point
when I made them and so I'm totally
vegan after my heart attack man I went
vegan used to be happy now [ __ ] vegan
and said so there are a bunch of vegan
jokes in the movie and this little
sequence here allowed Silent Bob to have
his first onscreen kiss and and that's
of course with his real-life wife
right here you know I'm doing a [ __ ]
emoji bed again but it backfires in
Silent Bob's face
and Kate made this work I'm a big fan my
silent scream right here uh but Kate
calls in there she is there she is my
girlfriend ladies a gentleman as a
mother my job Jennifer who was in Jay
and Silent Bob strike back as well
returns and she's playing Missy McKenzie
so she's she's the back story is that's
Colleen Mackenzie's mom the one we met
at all the at the the you know humanly
Gimli slider up in tusk and yo goes
there me and Jen go and they often in
the bathroom and make up a little
bathroom Bam Bam and meanwhile this is
the moment where Jay just like in Jay
and Silent Bob strike back he you know
found justice in a movies he's gonna and
fantasized about her he's gonna do the
same thing here obviously Bryan Aharon
playing another of his characters
because Brian played so many character
so many Hicks's in all the movies Dante
in the beginning I think this one would
be Gil Hicks no no that's not guilt is
he would be from all rest that would be
the one who did the news in Dogma the
co-anchor and stuff and so here we shot
all on a green screen the good folks at
encore put all those you know eggplants
and weed things there later on the peach
and whatnot Jay gets pegged in 2019 2020
version of Jay I mean even the old
version of Jay probably would like
beggin you saw any Mikkel first there
who had to education with he was our
shorter fry cook and Brian peeking over
the desk and then you know we jump out
of the fantasy and come back into this
sequence right here man there's DK who
helps the cells adds and right next to
them man that's Andy's Andy's daughter
Daisy a little bit she's in my Kilroy
Was Here movie so this point in the
flick man is when we kind of kick in
with the real flick up till now it's
just been us kind of aping Jay and
Silent Bob strike back but this is where
like oh we see you know justice and Jays
like my long-lost ex-girlfriend booboo
Kitty [ __ ] so you know we're gonna take
a side stop on our way to Hollywood and
that's gonna change everything every
night audience is applauded when me and
my wife made out and they always
applauded that joke where she's like I
just had some vegan where I just ate
some vegan there's Dave Mandel
double-fist in the coffee's this
sequence here right here where Jays like
write this [ __ ] down obviously shout out
Jay and Silent Bob strike back when we
were typing on the big movies Internet
term and all yummy that anymore you can
do it right on your phone so type all
you [ __ ] you're gonna pay you
are the one who is the hater ton you
know at any time we did stuff like that
like in the screenings you know and I
went to every damn screening 65,000
people just like not at once obviously
if it's spread out over the tour would
like go crazy it was so lovely man it
was like being a musician then playing a
certain chord and everybody's like I
know what songs max it was great we
picked a very John Hughes Ian looking
house I wrote that in the script a very
John
museum fair and there she is ladies and
gentlemen returning the great shannon
elizabeth let me tell you something we
made this me that she looks like we put
her in a box which sounds like [ __ ]
not not as nefarious as i mean but like
preserved her and then took her out for
this movie she looks the exact same
Shannon and J there's Harley's
introduction in the movie that's the
first time we see Millie and that was
her favorite thing to do was choke me
her father it was only supposed to
happen once but we kept doing it again
we let her choke like everybody she's
supposed to be whacking people out with
hockey sticks the whole movie but
instead she's like I did that in yoga
hosers and the stunt coordinator taught
her how to choke me out and she was like
I want to do that for everybody so it
became a running gag and stuff when JEB
put up a picture of Instagram of Jay and
Shannon together going hey look who's
back the day we shot Shannon holy [ __ ]
my Instagram blew up everyone loved that
photo and they were like oh there's one
of my favorite romances and I was like
what
that was a romance like what are you
like really but I was so happy that they
were happy to see her and stuff cuz we
were happy to see her and she crushes it
and she's the gateway to the rest of the
movie man like without her we can't say
that I mean I guess you could have but
it's fun to be like hey she who Jay you
know had sex with many years ago I had a
kid and that kid is Jay's long-lost
daughter this io this entire [ __ ]
like hey I got a kid too well nature and
that's what happens in nature but Jay
and Sam Bob were in Canada of course for
Degrassi and so Degrassi the next
generation was literally just kind of
like hey spike had a baby all those
years ago so that baby would be
age-appropriate right now to go to high
school so same thing here it's like Jay
and justice I mean that movie was 18
years ago so that mean they would
possibly you have a kid and so that
opened up the door for me to include my
kid I love this scene I love this whole
movie don't get me wrong but like every
night this is my this is where the movie
really kicks in for me because it's
funny you don't get me wrong but like
this is where you get to see Jay act and
then of course you know I get to see my
kid
my third league came out of my balls
ladies and gentlemen that's very you
know as a rare thing to say his director
so I was proud of her because she
crushed it and stuff like that
um another emoji gag Sanjay particularly
crushed it man he gets to do stuff in
this movie he's never done before
dramatically speaking so I love this is
where it movie kicks in and the score
that Jim Venable did for this movie I
loved Jim score for Jay and Silent Bob
strike back and when he I brought him
onto this I was like I tempt God when I
did the edit of the movie I tempt tenth
the movie that's where you put a attempt
score in their attempt it was gotta make
sure we're still recording we are I
tempt it with Jim's Jay and Silent Bob
strike back score so you know when I
handed him the movie he was like so
flattered because this is like oh my god
he used all my music I was like I love
that score mask be tough to ever beat
that score Jay and Silent Bob strike
back one of my favorite scores Dan that
and that and then this one the theme you
know we couldn't use that one because we
would had to buy that score so Jim was
like you know I that couldn't I can grow
the score can grow up and the boys can
sound a little different so the score
are the main theme is and Anna dan dan
dan dan but in this sequence we play
this he plays his piano cue which he
gave a different name to but I always
called I do know this whenever we talk
about he'd like his daughter or whatever
it goes into the piano Oh breaks my
heart thank God I got the volume down
because it would make me cry
particularly in the later scenes and
stuff um this is a little inside joke of
course we're you know Jays like what are
you telling me for he's the one with the
big mouth because I do for the very big
[ __ ] mouth it's always flapping
flapping as you can hear right here man
this was like the scene that they would
show on
we went on The Colbert show me and Jay
ever when I went on Seth Meyers
this is probably the most TV safe and
there's Trishelle enters the movie man
Trishelle plays Sophia Sophie and her
Harley became real good friends and
whatnot
Harley learned sign language for the
movie merit ASL American Sign Language
and so they could communicate all for
the flick Trishelle is wonderful I love
her death because she essentially she's
wonderful actress but she's playing a
version of Silent Bob in the movie so
her and I throughout the whole movie
were kind of like mirrors and bonded
over the fact that like our acting is
not about words but being very
expressive with our faces and hands so
it added an interesting element to
shooting that I've never done I had to
deal with before it never worked with
before was we had some ASL translator on
set every day that Rochelle was on set
so I would communicate the scene and
then I would communicate the scene to
true Shales translator and she would
communicate the scene in ASL back to
Trishelle so it was a added step than
I've ever had to deal with before but it
was who was totally fine he's even
wonderful to watch and you know it
always it right out outside to the side
of the camera her translator was always
there working and stuff that's what I
remember
one of the things I remember most about
the movie because I'd never had that on
another movie set before here is one of
my favorite jokes in the flick man where
Silent Bob reveals is is well Jay
reveals is one favorite movie and saw
Bob says it's the second favorite movie
is the shape of water and he does this
by looking at her trophies look how
impressed we are quick shot I remember I
was like hey man just Pan the [ __ ]
trophies and shadow mine use a quick
cutaway I like the yo methods and we
just turned around all of this I thought
they played very well together Harley
and Shannon as as mother and daughter
but it's a trip for me you know
naturally Harley's playing Jays daughter
in the movie but she's my daughter so
you know the whole movie like my
daughters and every
am seen I'm in this everyday I'm seen
with my daughter as she plays Jays
daughter was very met affair as we were
as I was writing it as routing it and
stuff like that and I was so happy for
the kid
she started studying Stella Adler
you know she wound up being in Quentin's
movie one spent time in Hollywood she
auditioned and got that and stuff so by
the time she came to my set man she was
you know much stronger actress than the
one that I had worked with on yoga
hosers not to say like she was bad she
was a kid back then but oh so I was so
happy for the great rosario Dawson
returning ladies and gentlemen not
playing Becky playing Reggie some people
in the theaters were like him then how
come shooting reference [ __ ] clerks
to him like well because she's not
playing her character from clerks to
whenever rosario now the live-action
Asoka from the next mandalorian season
season two how amazing is that
and that's something she really wanted
she came to us she was shooting zombie
land too and they weren't gonna let her
leave a set but she broke away for half
a day to come shoot with us max they
were in Atlanta and we were in New
Orleans so she wasn't shooting but she
was on hold but she was like I'm coming
anyway and came out and did this half
day for us man whenever she walked down
screen audience went absolutely nuts
it's thunderous no matter where you were
in the building if you were in the
backstage area go in the bathroom look
watch there's area put a thumb up for
like thumb dick a J right here so I
would say 25% of people when they saw it
live saw that most people looking at
Shannon she speaks some people looking
up and they see Rose area go like this
and there would always be this little
wave of laughter and stuff and so not
obviously Chicago this is a street in in
New Orleans and having Jay have a
daughter is an idea that I stole from
Jay in real life he has daughter
he's got Logan and has had her for well
she's coming up on five years old man
she'll be five years old on on April 1st
so you know Jay is always the guy least
[ __ ] likely the guy he made fun of
captain irresponsibility and show
and he turned out to be the world's
greatest [ __ ] dad no lie hands down
Jason means the best father I've ever
seen in my life and I include myself as
a dad in that equation I include my own
father as a dad in that equation I
include the Lord our God in that
equation is because he was also dad but
if you read that book you know he's
pretty shitty to his son so maybe we
don't include him but but Jay is an
amazing dad man like him and his kid
relate to one another like they're best
friends like every kid thinks their
parent hung the moon but like we all
loved Jay man we've been watching movies
25 years imagine if you had that 365
24/7 just for you a one-man [ __ ] show
and he's already working in kids
material likes new cheap oh cheese and
[ __ ] Oh Logan doors a man and he adores
her right back and is adorable because
like she's four and a half and he's 45
and they meet at the exact same maturity
level but their relationship inspired
the movie I was like if Jay go figure
you the guy leaves likely man I God we
wouldn't [ __ ] trust with a carton of
[ __ ] eggs let alone another human
being if you're such a great dad what
would your character be like man and so
boom that's kind of where the whole
middle act or whether meat of this movie
came from was inspired by Jay Mewes
being at that
and Harley playing his daughter was
inspired by the Instagram audience
because for years I'd put up a picture
of me and Harley together on Instagram
and you know as always a couple
wiseacres who are like I don't know bro
you know look at that blond hair man she
and she looks a lot more like Jay than
Silent Bob you might want to talk to
your wife so years later I was like [ __ ]
you I'm stealing your joke and making a
center point of my movie and stuff so I
love this scene once again we didn't
drive around we're just on a green
screen and whatnot we were in the same
building we shot the blunt cave we
parked a car and did our thing man put
up some damn green screen Ron who was
our DP this movie looks amazing and it's
all because of Lera for because of Ron
he did such an amazing an amazing job
he worked faster than me and I work fast
cuz I'm gonna [ __ ]
about what things look like and stuff I
won't get the jokes captured but ROM was
able to make the movie look really good
I remember as I was putting it together
I was like don't look like strike Magnus
is dark and like you know he's like well
you made that movie like [ __ ] 20
years ago with all the whites on he's
like you know cinemas a little different
now
so he went out of his way and made a
[ __ ] beautiful goddamn movie forest
man this we were just sitting inside and
this is all green screen in the
background and whatnot
and I love this sequence because there's
me and my kid and him I mean there's a
lot of sequences in the movie like that
Erik Carrasco is the guy driving the cab
the the the ride me now car if you will
ponds edibles they're actually real the
when it when he goes there's weeding
that java hilary Shuchi boys knows
you're gonna see Erik look at oh he's
acting Erik wrote one of my Supergirl -
oh my super girl episodes he wrote
masters the universe Netflix show with
me and stuff one of my favorite writers
and he came up visit and I said get the
[ __ ] in there man put him in there if
you visit Kevin Smith movie you will
wind up in the flick Harley was in Jay
and Silent Bob strike back as a little
baby like she played baby Silent Bob so
it hardly just proves if you stick
around long enough you'll go from an
extra incomes movie to the third lead
okay man hey there they are
it's method and read coming up man well
you know you hear them there they are
method and read we got so lucky that the
boys were willing to make a trip down in
New Orleans and and play with us
method had come and done an episode of
comic book men you know a couple seasons
back so I had an in with the miles to
know
read who does his makeup and stuff and
did on the show
pass the mic drop the mic that I had
done Jensen's show so you know I met him
and we played around one day when we
were doing that show so then I reached
out I was a gay man we originally had
written a scene with all the cinematic
stoners got together so his method and
read is Harold and Kumar Seth and Franco
from from pineapple express bill and Ted
Cheech and Chong but couldn't pull it
off so you know instead this became the
sequence if and it's kind of I mean I've
watched it every [ __ ] night in the
audience went nuts the audience was
disappointed when the rest of the movie
wasn't method and read or how high to
tell I told Method Man I was like if
you're if you have any brains whatsoever
you will make how I - based on what I
saw on the road they will show the [ __ ]
up my friend make I out how I to read
was absolutely sterile and their dynamic
while shooting very similar to me and J
it was adorable this was a tough night
because we had like 6 7 things doing
this day originally we're gonna shoot
this sequence on a basketball court but
then at the last minute I was like let's
do in a car method and red meat in a car
in in how high so let's just call that
back man so Ron set this up and and we
shot two different days me and junior on
a soundstage method or a door in a
parking lot in the same place where we
did chronic on this shop belongs to Ron
man he was like please let me do this
shot and I was like ah I don't know he
goes whoa blows past I was like I'm all
right and it was one of the greatest
shots for the live screenings of the
movie because as it came up on you know
the camera came up on his s sounds
dirtier than I meant to the audience
went nuts no and you know I shoot that
every night and send it to Ron and be
like this is your joke you're getting
this laughs right here Aparna joins the
show man Aparna Brielle playing ji ha
and then there's Alice Alice when
playing Shenmue for us the now our girl
gang is together just like in Jay and
Silent Bob strike back
we've got four you know girls on the
road who aren't quite being honest about
what they're on the road for however you
know the girls of 2001 and the girls of
2019 / 2020 the women if you will are
much different so we get to play with a
bunch of themes this is where we make a
lot of you know kind of jokes about
dragging Jay and Silent Bob from the 90s
into the present a lot of fish out of
water like is this what the world's like
now you know obviously they were baffled
by [ __ ] rideshares and [ __ ] so the
idea of a multicultural influence you
know they come from a pretty lily-white
world as we've seen in most of those
beers ski movies I got to play with that
here where it's like it's a much bigger
and different world and this one looks
kind of closer to the real world then
the first one did but in any event we
get the four we get a girl group hanging
out together man just like we did in the
other movie Jay's got a special
relationship with one in the girl group
and stuff and of course that would be
milli Millennium Millennium Falcon if
you will Falken so you know and all that
was missing at that point was you know
the van which we're gonna add in a
couple seconds the band's gonna show his
podcast stuff has been around for a long
time as in the earliest drafts of the
script at one point Shenmue was a
handler of a kid who Teddy
his name was going to be who at the end
of the movie would have turned out to be
a robot the whole time moons
early early draft you got to remember
I'm a STONER instead I came to the
eventual Oceania was there you know
she's the she's a spy she's not who she
represents herself to be the van is kind
of looks like the van from Jay and
Silent Bob strike back that was that was
my that was the intention I actually
asked them I said can you get something
[ __ ] close to this and that van is a
reference to references man one two like
me my family went out of
and vacation across country once when I
was like 5 years old but also its from
the bad news but not the same van but
the Bad News Bears and braking training
the Bears steal a van and then go drive
across country to Houston to playing
Little League World Series at the
Houston Astrodome and so that's where
you know I realized oh my god this
movie's got a lot of Bad News Bears in
it as far as I'm concerned and not for
the obvious places it's more subtle it's
more about you know Jay and and Millie
kind of function like Buttermaker and
Amanda you know an adult and a kid in
this relationship that are you know not
a relationship that's like you know hey
old man you know anything good you don't
know anything that kind of thing they're
doing it movies for years and stuff but
it very much so reminded me like as I
was watching the movie as I was making
it here blueprints were back man you
know little reference to Jane Sambas
past it's in the DNA from the kid passed
on from the dad passed on to the kid so
I you know the there's Buddy Christ on
the dashboard there's a much longer
sequence we saw right there that when
they jumped in and have totally missed
the sequence where the guy was wearing
the mask and stuff like that much at one
point like the borne on you seen the end
credits that Mickey played that
character you seen the end credits that
yeah it was cut it out that he was not a
pedophile and stuff but you know when I
cut the movie together I'm like how it
works better if he is but if Allen J
beats him up and they take the van and
stuff this moment here a little quiet
moment allows you to you know show look
at Harley's nodding at him when Jays
like being confronted with like [ __ ]
something he'd never heard before
honor killing and stuff like that he
reacts the only way he knows how and
stuff and hardly can kind of the
Millie's character you see she's kind of
agreeing with him so building a
relationship the scene is necessary
because you get to see the connection
between
mean father-and-daughter start to build
even though they don't know that their
father and daughter Harley hated
shooting the scene cuz she talked about
[ __ ] Chris Hemsworth right while you
know sitting there on set and she was
just like that's mortifying dad I'm like
it's all for [ __ ] fake if you listen
the guy had a voice box you know welcome
to Moody's bit of moonlight that's
Steven rout he came in at the last
minute did a bunch of voiceover he does
all the voices of the [ __ ] knocker [ __ ]
mandos later on we don't see him because
he wasn't there when we shot it but
you'll hear him later on - I love this
scene right here this is I no matter
where I was during the screenings on the
road I would be sure to shoot this
because I loved the silence the scene
people reacting watching the scene I
loved watching Jay get emotional I loved
watching the people watch Jay get
emotional I think Harley kills it in the
scene so every night it was real fun to
watch and real gratifying as well and he
knows it was a little nerve-wracking
because like it's a park parking park we
you know we're gonna drive through at a
movies
our second movies and you know we're
just gonna sit around and talk for a
minute
and a few minutes so I was always like
oh I hope the audience goes for this I
hope this isn't where they get up and go
get a drink or something like that but
it played it really played know is
always so happy it's always so happy for
Harley man you know as a dad I was just
proud but as a director I was like
[ __ ] a man well done so it was nice
to watch every night people kind of go
for the story you know is it's weird is
this to say there is you know a love
story at the center of the movie and
it's the story that apparent the love
the parent feels for kid the love that a
kid feels for a parent and stuff so you
know that's where I am in life
I got a kid I don't want right there in
the movie well that name about her I
love that [ __ ] saw above so shitty
when he's like no it's not a reboot this
line right here I could that my kid this
line right here I could not [ __ ]
believe destroyed every night man when
he was just like an added youth and
diversity to it
I thought it was like Club
I was like ah that's that's one of my
favorite lines in the movie because it's
some clever writing was set up earlier
in the movie and we pay it off here but
I was always so delighted the audience
like it was as soon as he was like youth
and diversity to it and then he goes
into the next line the audience would
pick it up and get it and like and it's
always a big applause moment I loved
that to death man that was one of my
favorite things watching my favorite
parts of the evening watching the movie
with the audience was that because made
me feel like oh I'm a smart writer I
could have been a smart writer if I
really tried so I like whenever he
refers to me is mr. teint who's too tame
like yes I am mr. tank
I've Jason Mewes in this movie and you
know I've always loved Jason Mewes I
he's always my rocket sauce my secret
weapon my I wouldn't be anywhere in life
without him man like there'd be no Jane
Samba we wouldn't be making these movies
if I'd never met Jay and he is so
wonderful in this movie he has moments
that make me [ __ ] laugh out loud and
cry even though I've seen cry laughs and
even though I've seen the movie many
many times I was there when we made and
I wrote the [ __ ] lines and said and
then he has moments that like grab me in
the [ __ ] heart and this moment here
right here is one of my favorite in the
flick the it's you know glassy-eyed time
and you know kid she's kind of into like
you know she can make herself cry real
easy and stuff as an actor Simona
but Jay getting emotional that's like I
couldn't count on that [ __ ] like that
that was new and that line right there
no you didn't always [ __ ] destroy it
every night it was so awesome here he's
coming up right here he gets kind of a
glassy eyed and he looks too solid Bob
at one point son Bob can't help him I
remember in the Edit I was like that's
the story there when he looks to sama
bums not there it just happened before
and sama bumpkin I looked away and Jay
was like by himself look at this man
like he [ __ ] crushes this you know
some people were lawyers
[ __ ] won't [ __ ] some cats got mad
but I'll give a [ __ ] Jay [ __ ] crushed
that moment man
and also this movie has woke things in
it and it also has jokes about wool the
things in we try to have our cake and
eat it too man you know movies about
look at these guys being dragged from
the 90s into the [ __ ] present-day and
Fred returns we shot this on such a
[ __ ] rainy night you can't tell but
it's raining it wasn't as raining as
hard at that particular moment we ran
outside and [ __ ] shot this but if you
look at the puddles behind us on the
ground you'll see some [ __ ] water
hitting those puddles same movies that
we pulled up to in Chicago we just used
the other side of it we didn't go to a
completely different set make a whole
new movies the same [ __ ] building
fred is strapped to the roof of the car
you know I remember he had a harness on
him and stuff like that and he killed
that his whole hater tots there or at
least choking him out again just like
she choked Kevin silo Bob and then
she'll choke Kevin Smith coming up his
hater tots filled with hay like that was
him I remember when he did it I laughed
out loud you could hear me in the
background the raw footage [ __ ]
laughing and cackling at that [ __ ]
line hey this line always got a big
laugh from where with the screenings and
whatnot the audience go nuts Jay I love
Jays delivery ditch okay guys what the
[ __ ] is deliveries perfect that's a kid
who spent 25 years perfecting a
character man and he just chefs kiss
that delivery just rolled off his tongue
so well you never really see Silent Bob
drive I think that may be a cinematic
first you saw Jay driving in dog mode
when we were doing this [ __ ] and he's
like gear obviously James I'll Bob have
learned to drive since that movie that
is a little reference to you know double
reference when we open the door Jay hey
Jay and Silent Bob are in his house and
strike back which we called back when we
go to she have two justices ass but
that's also us doing this [ __ ] is when
we turned around from with the monkey
huddle and stuff in Jay and Silent Bob
strike back okay I remember well the
Klan sequence like you got to remember I
grew up in the 80s so all the road
movies
watch had like Klan seen him and stuff
like that and they always get their
comeuppance my kid did not grow up
watching those movies Chris Jericho
ladies and gentlemen so when she read
this in the scriptures like dad you
can't include that like the Klan is a
hate group and I was like yeah I know
that's why we do what we do to them in
the movie and stuff is she's gonna know
you can't even put him in a movie people
like that would really make people upset
and I was like God like you know I mean
I think like it's a comedy and everybody
understands like we're certainly not on
the side of the [ __ ] Klan and stuff
and her and my wife Jennifer was like I
don't know you might want to cut that
man and at one point I cut this entire
sequence out of the movie and the movie
was shorter and then I was like a
journey feels too short
this always played incredibly well not
only is Chris Jericho amazing in the
movie but Silent Bob's got his whole
Glengarry Glen Ross speech here man this
is one of my favorite moments in the
movie when we did our public excreting
'he's because you know whatever somebody
from one of the other flicks or somebody
that people recognized showed up people
would [ __ ] applaud and [ __ ] like that
so when Jericho lifts up you know it's
good and we see that it's Chris Jericho
the artist villain and then they'd be
like wait I'm applauding Klansmen be
like well you know I like Chris but not
I don't it was it was really they were
confused reactions it was pretty funny
this is lifted right from Glengarry Glen
Ross one of my favorite movies of all
time the Alec Baldwin monologue when I
started making movies in the 90s you
could reference movie dialogue and you
know all day long and [ __ ] we lift up
lines wholesale from other movies and
[ __ ] like that now in this day and age
it was interesting I learned that like
we couldn't do this without new line
saying yes Warner Brothers announced new
line saying that we could do the
dialogue in the movie because its
dialogue they own David Mamet had to
sign off on it too apparently and give
us permission to use the dialogue which
makes sense I guess at the end of the
day but when I started my career [ __ ]
you that's my name if people didn't get
where the scene was coming from it until
that moment that's when they were like
oh it's Glen Garry Glen Ross but every
night of the tour before I went out
there
I would set it up a little bit
and kind of make this Glengarry Glen
Ross coming because I knew I didn't set
it up well enough in the movie and [ __ ]
so the you know I dig this that look
like such an eighties movie with all
those Klansmen turning it once and I
love this hold on I I do I dig the fact
that I was Achilles racist Fox and Jays
like I got something better
we're a dump [ __ ] all over him and stuff
that is how stupid you dirty it says
sheep [ __ ] in the in the the line you
know the the commentary what does it
called the you know where they put the
words on the bottom of screen but it was
sheet [ __ ] there's live was a tour
manager and Shecky and that's my walk I
walk up there there's the scum and
villainy Cantina JC walking right in
front of it with this wife Jen there's
the improv or me and Ralph to babble on
all the time that's my Los Angeles you
know they always go to Hollywood and
they show you like there's the sign and
there's the [ __ ] this and this
there's my Hollywood but I'll always
love this here's his music there's that
piano music a little bit the Jim Venable
crushed I love this shot because in the
movie watching into the audience that
would make me well up because that's how
I feel every day of my life that I wake
up in Hollywood is where I live and I go
walk in and I see that sign and I'm like
holy [ __ ] we made it so when that
happened in the movie when it happened
every night that I watched it I felt it
right here Jay and Silent Bob strike
back
is really just a dirty version of the
Muppet movie and in the Muppet movie
they were just trying to get to
Hollywood same [ __ ] thing so this
comes from Jay and Silent Bob strike
back so at its DNA in its chords
creative DNA this is this is the Muppet
movie and they're just trying a bunch of
[ __ ] puppets just trying to get to
Hollywood for whatever reason because
they have the dream of the Rainbow
Connection if you will love this little
scene between the kid and Jay it's quiet
they crushed it when we shot and it was
a nice little respite when we were
theatrical because you're coming off of
you know the Klan scene and then we're
about to go into chronicon and stuff so
this is like the quiet moment scene and
was the only reference to Alanis
Morissette as god in the movie and then
we shot Matt after the movie was done
and then he references Alanis Morissette
as God earlier in the flick and stuff so
uh it undercut this moment a little bit
but it was kind of worth it cuz the
storyteller I feel it was worth it all
these fine people are fans and came down
with their own costumes and buried them
see those the big balloons those aren't
balloons those are the real Funko pops
designs that Funko it did for the
Bluntman and chronic pops and we I said
can I blow those up and make them like
they're giant floaty balloons parade
balloons they were like alright this
dream come true ladies and gentlemen
look at all that it's a sea of me you
know as a guy who's a big fan of [ __ ]
Kevin Smith the filmmaker and the person
like could you imagine how delighted I
was to walk around a room where everyone
was told half of the entire crowd was
dressed like me it's you know this is
like my dream John Malkovich like
Malkovich Malkovich Malkovich Malkovich
originally it was not meant to be a
chronic con and apologies to the great
Doug Benson who had done a movie a
documentary called chronic own but you
know ours is a reference of course to
Bluntman and chronic
so originally wasn't chronic own it was
San Diego comic-con and then I realized
I can't [ __ ] show
spider-man Batman all that IP I can't
have people walking around like that
like without permission and stuff so I
was like huh [ __ ] what's the point
because then it's like it's a vampire
and that's a robot and everybody's just
like that but then I was like wait a
second I do home Jay and Silent Bob so
if I everyone at the con if it's if it's
a con that's about Jane saw Bob and for
the longest time it was blunt con many
drafts and then one day I was like
chronic con and I didn't want to use it
because Doug had made a movie and I
didn't want to seem like I was stealing
but I was like come on man it just makes
more sense than blunt con so chronic
kind of became uh Adam Brody who I
absolutely adore man was with me and
cop-out was with me and
there's that t-shirt always got a huge
[ __ ] laugh captain rib mended that
t-shirt as well Harley is wearing Jays
shirt from Jay and Silent Bob strike
back and she didn't want to wear that
outfit she was like oh do I have to and
I was like yes the idea and the whole
third act of the movie is you're dressed
like Jay wasn't a Nissan Bob truck back
like follow my daughter a little [ __ ]
like that oh look at that there's the
biggest special effect we got in the
movie not because it's ala Graham
Chris [ __ ] Hemsworth is in the movie
man Thor himself how the [ __ ] did that
happen I believe me I'm still trying to
figure it out Chris had said some very
ade referenced me in a Vanity Fair
article about Thor Ragnarok and he said
like Kevin Smith said something about it
on his podcast I was like Thor knows my
name the god of [ __ ] thunder so you
know a year later whenever it was we
were two years later we're getting ready
to make this movie we're putting
together a cast let somebody reach out
to Chris Hemsworth he said my name that
one time and this is a beautiful story
about symmetry or in life or whatever
his manager or his agent one of them was
like you know the only reason I'm in
this business is because years ago I saw
a movie called clerks let's make this
happen
and made it happen man Chris we were in
post we shot him on a green screen and
stuff but he came out and he was doing
so many things he was gonna be on Ellen
that day as the same day all the
Avengers are on Ellen and then they they
were gonna fly to England for the
opening of the movie I think they were
on Kimmel as well so it was a busy day
and he made time to come and hang with
us it was really lovely
yet another cool cameo there's cat ears
REM behind Jay in the background which
goes to all our shows at scum and
villainy Cantina where we do fat man
beyond the good folks at Raw amongst
many people who brought their [ __ ] to
make our chronic Khan look [ __ ]
authentic and big it is you know it's a
ballroom at at a hotel in New Orleans
that we turned into her own little con
with a bunch of [ __ ] people dressed
like Kevin Smith knockoffs man oh
heavens so there's this this scene again
if you're into the comedy this movie you
like oh man they're gonna get serious
again I could hear
the piano I [ __ ] love the scenes well
my favorite things I've ever filmed in
my entire life I think Jay is wonderful
in it Harley is wonderful in it Jays
performance is right there no no wait a
minute like it's a soft it's real he's
not like [ __ ] you know big and
over-the-top and stuff it's pretty
emotional stuff and the day that like we
shot this it didn't say in the script
Jay rolls the tear gets glassy eyed
suddenly I'm Millie did but you know Jay
I did not say that about because I might
as well written Jamie pulls out a
20-foot [ __ ] you know some [ __ ] just cuz
you write it in a script and gonna
[ __ ] ever happen so I didn't write
Jay gets emotional but he did because
the kid was crying she could turn on the
tears in a movie the dropping [ __ ] hat
and stuff so she would do that and Jay
you know she's off camera we're on Jay
and she's Harley's crying off cam give
him the full performance that she gives
on camera and so Jay would get emotional
and stuff and so that's how he gets all
glassy-eyed cuz he's looking at Harley
and he saw Harley like getting emotional
and that made him sad so he was able to
kind of do this moment man like and I've
only seen Jay cry like three times in my
life that's what it looks like and the
end that's what it feels like Paul C
[ __ ] nailed it man you know I know
some people what [ __ ] your movie it
[ __ ] blows and it's stupid and you
suck and you always have and you're
gonna not have a job soon one day
they'll realize you know who didn't tell
me this [ __ ] for 25 years I don't give a
[ __ ] this is one of my favorite [ __ ]
things I've ever put on film
Jake crushed it and crushed it as did
Harley in the scene it's so damn
wonderful and so in the movie like it
was always like it went from that kind
of sad note to soon as they saw diedrich
bader 's ass as soon as we went up and
they heard whoa they knew it was him man
before he spoke the audience went nuts
or like an applause [ __ ] like
thunderous applause and [ __ ] my only
regret I love T jerk man and he gets a
reference since his Batman Brave and
Bold when he talks about the Hammers of
justice my only regret is then look you
don't [ __ ] age either he looks almost
the exact same my only regret is that
didn't have him say oh what a lovely tea
party I wish I hadn't say
could have put it in the credits and
[ __ ] but we were rushing so fast we shot
this in the same hallway where like
Ralph's airport is is right to the right
of that and stuff so you know in movie
sets you use a lot of things that are
close to one another so if we just pan a
little bit more to the right you would
see the elevators that are right there
Keith Coogan showed up on our [ __ ]
picture lazy um the dishes are done man
the fishes are done man
um it was a reference to the two of
course the movie dude don't tell Mom the
babysitter's dead which we talked about
SModcast me and motor years ago and
stuff so I was so delighted to make
those references and get Keith's good
show look at that a hallway of me a sea
of me and then we get into the fun and
running around the content stuff which
is mu lates running around mu studio
there's my mom I'm in back of my mom
right there and that's my brother right
next to me who's just like Jay Biggs and
Van Der Beek man Jason Biggs one of the
first persons that signed on to this
movie I love them to death
and Quinn Brian Quinn from Impractical
Jokers who used to work for me years ago
I'm pointing out him like he's on the
screen there's me and my mom I'm gonna
act with her in a minute man like you
know all the time on the movie I'd
always be there's Quinn I'd always be
like you know what any time we did
something that's like this this is why
we [ __ ] made the movie and [ __ ] like
that
today when that day when our students
that right there I give my thumbs up to
my mom she gives me a thumbs up I
remember that day going this is why I
shot the movie my 73 year old mother and
me are on camera together she was a lady
who's looking for milk at the end of
clerks or in Clark she was the milk maid
at the end of clerks - she's looking for
a moment so I was delighted over there
so for people like [ __ ] your movie I'm
like yeah but my mom's in it so [ __ ] you
this you know there's my brother my
brother Don who taught me things that
were funny so if you don't like my son's
you ever blame that [ __ ] dude Don
Diedrich chasing us through right into
the comic book man reunion panel this is
a much was a longer scene and I put the
rest of it up on instagram if you go to
my Instagram account that Kevin Smith
you could see it more of it but my boys
Brian and Walt were in there and Mike
and Ming
this was a bit that built slowly it was
supposed to be originally like
we run into two girls like the shining
girls who are dressed like Jay and
Silent Bob and they're like company with
us and then I wanna I was like can we do
them in black and white and then appears
I was like [ __ ] those two little girls
let's make it me and Jay and a clerk
scene and it's one of the biggest
moments of the movie people applauded in
this also one of the biggest moments in
the movie man I love sama Bob's reacted
to it which I acted out what he goes
boom because that is exactly how I felt
when this happened this shouldn't have
[ __ ] happen I did not write this
scene when I wrote this movie I had
never thought I'd ever talked to Ben
Affleck again in my life ladies and
gentlemen I hadn't spoke to him in close
to 10 years when this all happened but
I've told the story many times Kevin
McCarthy who reviews movies for Fox out
of Washington and stuff he when he
interviews people up for junkets that
have been in movies that I've made even
if they're in other movies they all do
of reference to the view askew movies
and like case in point I'll be
interviewing mat for Elysium and be like
hey man like when you guys gonna do a
Good Will Hunting - hunting season and
Matt will be like what the [ __ ] and be
like oh I was in that movie years ago
James how about Shrek back as a nice
icebreaker and stuff he did it for Ben
while we were in production and he was
like hey man they're making Jay and
Silent Bob reboot right now you're gonna
be in anticipate was like no nobody
called me and I'm not busy
Joey's in the movie man this always got
a huge thunderous applause - so uh when
Ben said that stuff on Twitter everyone
on production was like did you see this
dude receive been talking to you you
gotta reach out to him to be in the
movie I was like that's just some nice
[ __ ] to say on Twitter he's doing a
junket for a movie on Netflix triple
frontier
what is he supposed to do like [ __ ]
Kevin Smith by the way watch the triple
frontier on Netflix like now he's just
sales mode don't you think about that
and then I like a week later Jay which
came up to me he goes I was thinking
about it bro I think Ben's sending you a
coded message I was like you know what I
will reach out to him and see if he says
yeah I tweeted him I was about to tweet
him but then instead Jason's wife Jordan
was like don't [ __ ] tweet him text
him and I found a number I tried it and
suddenly we were having a conversation
and suddenly Ben was like I'll come pay
in the movie and I got to write this
scene which is like you know Kevin Smith
fan fiction man where it's just like oh
my god Holden and Alyssa out of baby C
that's my sister Virginia so my whole
family's in the movies
daddy's dead Virginia was sitting next
to Joey at the end of chasing amy man
remember she's the one that's like like
you know who's that I was some guy I
knew so putting my sister in the scene
allowed me to kind of make reframe
Chasing Amy
like as a love story that only kicks in
in the last two minutes of the movie
because really that's the couple that's
still together
is Virginia and Joey and stuff but
obviously her and hold and still have a
tight connection and I I what I love
about this scene as Holden grows up the
guy who we met in chasing amy never
could have been in the relationship he's
in now father of a child with somebody
who's not married to who's married to
somebody else in mobile but there he is
man everybody grows the under chase
gaming you get the idea when he shows up
the comic comic you like me one day
Holden will get up get a grip and [ __ ]
he does they're probably the little kid
without whom there is no movie minutes
Logan Lee muse right there and Logan and
you know being in our lives being in
Jays life particularly Henson our lives
kick this movie into gear in terms of me
going Jay as a dad Jays a good dad go
[ __ ] figure and her name being named
Amy come on when I wrote that scene man
I was like oh my god I was like what the
[ __ ]
like I'm so clever and I went up to
everyone on set I was like if holding an
Elissa had a baby what do you think
their baby's name would be that's J and
J was like I don't know Ben jr. Mike Ben
jr. what the [ __ ] Amy he goes why and
what could the movie was cause I [ __ ]
you and then I go on until somebody
else's stuff so I loved that I enjoyed
that man that was total Kevin Smith fan
fiction writing having a little kid to
cut to it was an easy wonderful thing
for editing purposes very simple seems
like to [ __ ] out three shots [ __ ]
every Kevin Smith movies very simple
scene Park and bark we're sitting we let
him talk and this [ __ ] speech he
gives this monologue that bandoliers oh
he utterly [ __ ] killed it in the best
possible way he said he was so happy to
the model guys like you crushed it man
everything you've seen here mostly from
the first take of the monologue I see
you crushed he goes you said everything
you wrote everything I wanted to say
right now
as a dad he's going who's absolutely
[ __ ] perfect it was easy for me to
throw out there because this is how I
feel
he didn't just execute the dialog he
elevated it man and that's you know been
talking but that's me in the movie you
know like god I'm in the movie as Silent
Bob and I'm in the movie as a fake
version of Kevin Smith but like the real
Kevin Smith you know didn't really have
a place in this movie other than like
you know I've got a kid and so I know
things about having kids now or whatever
[ __ ] but this scene which didn't exist
when I first saw that movie didn't exist
into the last week of the movie allowed
me to put myself in the movie
essentially what this scene is saying is
it's you know Kevin Smith going [ __ ] you
I love making movies with my kid like is
that simple you know for all the people
who like stop banging mows your kid you
[ __ ] suck for doing that I'm like
alright all this new stranger and
[ __ ] give up sure joy and making art
with my family because you don't want me
to so this scene is kind of me going
like this this is where I am in my life
right now and if you're not into that I
get that but this is what I want to do
and you know like clerks as well I know
what I wanted to do back then all rats
was or what I wanted to do back then
this is what I want to do right now and
you know I'll try to keep it like it
with the old stuff and funny and you
know hopefully edgy and stuff no edge
Lord but hopefully there's enough stuff
in there but I'm leaning way into the
heart man I've been doing that since
like chasing Amy to be fair so this one
you know you just don't expect it in a
James Bond movie but if you watch clerks
2 and you watch Jane saw Bob reboot
right next to each other they're kind of
sequel one and you know this is more or
less a sequel to clerks 2 in terms of
the emotional like the boys get to grow
up just like Dante and Randall grew up
and here we get to do to Sears and
excellent Ben Affleck little [ __ ]
puns and [ __ ] and he got to act with
Jace kid one day Jace kid will grow up
we're gonna make one more Jay and Silent
Bob movie and I love you you were
amazing in that movie thank you
for elevating air flow we're gonna make
one more of these movies we're gonna
wait 15 years with Logan's 20 and then
Logan can be the third lead of the movie
and Jay and Silent Bob will have to go
to Hollywood to stop another iteration
of a blonde man in chronic but this time
they'll make the journey with Jays
granddaughter and Logan will play Logan
Jays daughter will play Jays
granddaughter and Harley will play
Logan's mom so that we all live long
enough folks we're talking about 15
years from now
that'll there's your next chain saw Bob
movie Dan Fogler the great Dan Fogler
man who came out and shot that [ __ ] at
2:00 in the morning kids and was still
funniest [ __ ] man managed to wring
laughs out of a very quick screen
appearance this is our chronic con it
looks exactly like San Diego comic-con
or chronicon logo resembles the chronic
San Diego comic-con logo that's because
good folks comic-con international
signed off and said oh my god feel free
Kevin and that was really sweet man
because chronic comic-con is obviously a
big deal to me we get to meet Kevin
Smith the director we saw him very role
in movie and stuff
you know again this is I remember when
we made Jay and Silent Bob strike back
years ago 18 years ago some people were
like it looks like a big expensive
[ __ ] fan film somebody literally says
it's we're on YouTube like it's like a
20 million dollar YouTube fan film and
that's because I'm a big fan of Kevin
Smith but it's too early to be a big fan
Kevin Smith I guess that was kind of
gross but you know after the heart
attack and I've been doing these movies
for 25 years people then get um a dick
so much this time Ballack ill he's just
[ __ ] put himself at all his friends
in the [ __ ] book I love lines like
this where she goes I hate this guy
forces his kid being everything you mix
I mean I'm sure she loved delivering
that [ __ ] - I loved [ __ ] being this
guy man again
like this better than I've ever looked
in my life in a movie and [ __ ] so I was
happy like to capture this I wasn't
supposed to be the guy on stage and the
original drafts in the movie Stan Lee
was the guy on stage that the you know
spoilers it's about to happen later but
that the bad guys are going after not
Kevin Smith that doesn't make sense but
we lost Stan and so I had to obviously
change the flick although we do get Stan
popping up at the end they
she is one of the first people sign on
this movie Melissa Benoist man who's
currently with kid man her and Chris
Boyd gonna have a super baby
I said don't put that baby in nope
capsule and rocking it off this [ __ ]
planet Val Kilmer lays a gem he's about
to take off that mask Schwalm there is
Batman himself he his manager had sent
me an email and said he's Val's gonna be
in town in New Orleans with his Mark
Twain movie and so we got to talking I
was like hey we're shooting this movie
we've got a lot of cameos you want to
come play in it and he was like I don't
know if you can follow the news but I
have a hard time speaking I've had some
health issues he's gone so perhaps if I
was to come play I could play Simon
busts some poor cousin to Silent Bob he
wrote he's a very eloquent writer and I
said oh my god you have no idea how
close you are I was that you know I need
somebody to play blunt man in our blunt
man v cronic movie and he wrote back oh
my god that'd be fun do you know I
played Batman once it was like yes Bell
I I heard that once I think that little
shoot in a canister I literally did this
bit in an episode of Supergirl with
Melissa where Manchester black like
shoots something at her and she catches
it and it explodes in her face so if I
could just bit the bit again minute to
rob this movie there's tons of moments
where I'm like I stole for myself it
stole from something else this was huge
for me man look at that man Tommy Chong
in the movie playing Alfred the butler
he was just bliss and gave us every
delivery we needed these three cats in
this blunt man v cronic movie an encore
Armand Kevorkian did our backgrounds and
stuff that's all green-screen he made a
big cave for us and the car that's
behind balanced stuff this none of the
actors were ever in the same frame or
together they were never in the same
room together we shot
Melissa by herself then we shot Val by
him stuff and then we shot Tommy by
himself on three different occasions and
you know just edit it together and blah
blah but you know you'll see there's no
like
master of everybody together and you
know what doesn't [ __ ] matter because
at the end of the day is about jokes
nobody's looking at this movie going
like oh it better be you know visually
the eloquent like you know it's
certainly visually more visually
eloquent probably than Jane salbo showed
back just because I've 20 years ago and
I've grown up as a filmmaker but you
know it's I'm more about like let's get
in close we could see them talking in
[ __ ] but these cats were great and right
here the BAM would have been you know
cock-knocker and stuff and and
unfortunately it's that guy we cut back
to Kevin Smith what a letdown you'd
almost heard the audience every night be
like what because there was no Mark
Hamill man well you know there's a world
of difference kids between 2001 when we
made Jane Silent Bob strike back and
there were no worse no more Star Wars as
ever and 2019 when we made Jay and
Silent Bob reboot and Disney you know
has dictated that there's nothing but
Star Wars us so we reached out to Mark
and he was like it was hey man you wanna
be cock-knocker and Jane saw Bob reboot
news like the Empire won't let me so we
just didn't cast the part again we
didn't put somebody else's cock-knocker
but after haven't seen the movie on tour
over and over again
I realized third night of the show I
said to Jason [ __ ] we missed the
opportunity we shoulda like fist comes
through the wall Melissa goes off [ __ ]
and then you cut to [ __ ] knocker and
it's Kevin James I was like we could
have just thrown him me on some green
screen [ __ ] I don't know the guy but
like it would've been a phone call to
find out but oh well we missed it man
maybe he let me we do the special
edition like where we put Jabba back in
and [ __ ] I could put in Kevin James but
smog squad behind us man those are all
cats that go to a lot of Spawn casters
particularly fat man beyond Big Daddies
over there man
Brian stoner Chris lovely people [ __ ]
people and stuff whole crowd there's all
fans mana there's Mike he made that
actual jacket the smoking jacket the
Blazer if you will we're in George
Carlin on my chest kids he couldn't be
there with us for strike back but he's
there with me on my chest and reboot
there's all my wardrobe behind me you
see my purple coat my jorts hanging
enough
like that and jerseys that I don't
really wear anymore and then this was a
bit that you know me and Ron had a good
time with we were like let's do a little
bit of Marx Brothers and stuff so you
know the its we only do one shot that
really ties us together and the rest is
just meat cutting to me and me and me
this is you know as a big Kevin Smith
fan and a narcissist I love this whole
sequence every shot is me it's like oh
my favorite actor my favorite actor my
favorite actor and then my favorite
actress pops up and chokes me out and
stuff we're getting into the wacky third
act ladies and gentlemen were you know
all hell breaks loose and I get to tell
a joke that I've been trying to tell for
[ __ ] five years at this point there's
Joe right here man you'll recognize him
he was the ad excuse me
in Jay and Silent Bob strike back and he
was lovely enough to come back and do it
again and he's responsible for the house
party for reference how's it going I did
what I need us at you go in and do one
for you and he threw in the house party
for roses and Ching I'll take that so
anytime somebody from strike back popped
up it was you know the audience dug it
and and right they're like I'm wearing a
ponytail because I'm supposed to be
Silent Bob playing Kevin Smith and it's
kind of a little shout out to the very
end of the cut sequence of the old
version of clerks man I came in with a
long ass ponytail and like looked around
and stuff but you know you can't I when
someone's like you've arrogant [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] like I get it because I
put myself all over the [ __ ] movie
but you know what if you're gonna make a
movie and you remotely want to be in it
you better put yourself all over here
because nobody else gonna cast me in
[ __ ] movies and [ __ ] and then BAM
this one switch happens and stuff and
shan-yu reveals that she's not a
podcaster from China ah
there's Chris Wood as Melissa's husband
sitting right next to Jesse who plays
Brainiac on Supergirl
I come from Supergirl world from time to
time the [ __ ] knocker [ __ ] meant there's
mark barnard and ladies and gentlemen
playing with Sleepypod KITT yes sir my
fat
and beyond co-host the commence
collusion plants is firmly in 2018-2019
country and stuff the this is you know
the comparatively to strike back this is
when the you know the girls show up with
the diamonds you know when the boys are
on the blunt man chronic set and the
this moment here killed in the all the
screenings where j was like one of them
was wearing a [ __ ] cat suit one of
them was brain cancer I [ __ ] knew it
and stuff that ain't me being thrown
that's a stunt guy but this is me
popping up because I'll do that but I
ain't getting [ __ ] thrown at really I
just didn't want to make two people
carry me heavy metal scrap you out our
scrap is metal man and there's our first
look at a joke a boos I was trying to
tell five years iron Bob barely a joke
more of a reference but iron Bob this
entire third act with a con and iron Bob
and and and terrorism comes from the
mall rats to script originally and the
it wasn't chronic on it was comic-con
and it wasn't Russian terrorists they
were Canadian terrorists in mall rats
too so you know here since I was writing
the script while in a news cycle where
was nothing but Russians collusion just
didn't worked its way into the movie and
stuff somebody asked me if there was a
reference to Bill Murray when I say how
yes I can't act I just steal all my [ __ ]
from other people that I've seen act and
stuff but I enjoyed playing this version
of Kevin Smith I wish I had a better
line than the jorts where there are
other lines that could went with but I
left them in there but I do I mean this
is arrogant ass and I'm sure I'm [ __ ]
in the comments people like you [ __ ]
suck or hell and I faded you my whole
life
but as a big Kevin Smith fan I love
that's delivery right there you've been
talking to my wife that thought I was
just watching that movie I'd be like
[ __ ] well done remember Ferg connect
once again beautiful looking scene man
the lighting and [ __ ] thanks to Ron our
DP who was just absolutely [ __ ]
amazing
Alice gets to speak the whole movie
she's mostly been quiet you know one
point she said brunt man but now she
gets to monologue and soliloquized and
whatnot and do the villain speech and
I'm so happy for her because for most of
the movie she was wearing that black wig
and stuff and not saying anything but
you know here she just owned the [ __ ]
show until she was in a frame with me
and then I was constantly [ __ ]
ad-libbing and stuff you hear that one
guy go buddy say that's Steven this was
one of the biggest laughs and moments in
the movie where J you know tells not
just tells her you know you're I'm your
father but also you know where he tells
the story about lying or why sometimes
it's okay to break a promise or
something like that not lying wait he's
gonna do it in a second because it
killed every time we watched it public
screaming and they all you'd spend
[ __ ] nuts he's like breaking the
problems is the right [ __ ] thing to
do right we did this about 10 times poor
J walking and talking can be tough for
him and so we had to keep doing it over
and over but when we got to it oh the mo
juice if you will but out when he was
just like I didn't because I told your
mom I didn't I wouldn't come in her and
he his eyes go wah I'd all [ __ ] kills
me Ben Gleib jumping up tossing that
[ __ ] gun he's got an ad lift line
here that I didn't write this line where
you go I would it be real he said that
that just made me [ __ ] laugh now
we're into the part of the movie where
things are just getting [ __ ]
ridiculous I mean the whole movies goofy
and stupid but now things are very
untethered from reality
guns are drawn you know this goes this
you know why I realized I I grew up
watching movies in the 80s and all my
favorite movies like Animal House and
Caddyshack they always have like third
acts that go like off the rails wherever
the all hell breaks loose and stuff like
that and those are the movies that grew
up watching so naturally those the
movies I wound up emulating later on in
my career in my life and stuff so yeah
it's one of those you know like the
third act is kind of nuts it would have
made more sense if it was staying
we were gonna have this cool sequence
where you know Stan is on stage with
them and then after iron Bob burst him
which is just about to happen Shen you
saw this J and Millie and jihad and so P
took Stan and ran away with Stan and so
they chased you know areas ladies and
gentlemen
Iren Bob I love the way Jason siren I'm
not in the suit there's another Kevin in
the suit and he's the guy that was in
the first Iron Man movie with Robert
Downey jr. and there's a speaking of
which that we you know remember when
he's like no gang signs he's a guy right
go up try to throw up the gang size that
guy is the guy who played our iron Bob
and so while we're shooting he was like
it was nice to be in this suit this time
for change that was fun so the in this
sequence the you know we the third act
becomes as big and [ __ ] silly as as
it does because you know [ __ ] it's a
movie and stuff and we've accomplished
lots of stuff we have to do like you
know we had to get the father and
daughter together and we kind of already
did that to some point and stuff like
that so at this point it's just let's
have fun and this speech was in almost
every iteration of the script and Jay
treated it so [ __ ] seriously learned
valerian by heart practiced over and
over again the first screening we had
was the premiere at the Chinese Theatre
Man will remain and Jay put our hands
and feet in the cement in the forecourt
amazing [ __ ] honour that happened to
us that was the day of the premiere but
at the premiere all of it premieres like
you know industry premieres generally
speaking aren't like [ __ ] like fan
screenings and [ __ ] you know there were
more reserved and stuff so in that
premiere screening people weren't like
going crazy about Jay doing valerian and
he was like I remember he was a cop man
I thought everyone looked like that and
then when we went on tour very first
screening was dirty and when he did that
speech like every night he did that
speech the audience blended like nuts
and started applauding and so you know
when he was on tour with us he was like
they did like it this is of course
ridiculous all of it is but the KGB
sonic disrupter but this gives us a
chance to let Sophie have a hero moment
man and every night that Trishelle
delivered this line hearing is so if I
can overrate it the audience all [ __ ]
applauded and stuff I love our Bob
knockin chairs over I love this shot
[ __ ] let's get aggressive girls aah
and then they dive into it and stuff
this you know if you gave me another 10
million make this movie we made it for
like eight million bucks you gave me
another 10 million to make this movie
the sequence would probably look the
exact [ __ ] same I love this flick oh
my god I thought you loved this reboot
as he says right there on screen so if
you know I if you can at me all you want
if you're like [ __ ] this movie is
terrible and I [ __ ] hate you and you
suck as a filmmaker
that's totally fine this movie is
exactly what I wanted it to be so I'll
take all the heat if you didn't like it
cuz this is this was my [ __ ] vision
man and it was executed it was elevated
beyond what I hoped it would ever [ __ ]
be we bring us to the day numa's bunch
of cut stuff in there we're gonna do it
after you know the con scene with Will
Ferrell as will and Holly as as the not
federal wildlife marshal but Department
of Homeland Security marshal will and
Holly but since we had the benzene come
in at the end of the week end of
production the last week a production I
was like you know what we don't need
that stuff we got gold there and stuff
and so the movies are any like an hour
hour 45 so as like alright I can let
that go and we cut it while we were in
production while or shooting and I was
like let's stop we don't need that we'll
go inside do something more important
but I love this I loved bringing her
Harley or Millie if you will to the
front of quick stuff it's a very Snoopy
Woodstock moment to me and I was big
peanuts kid grown-up man Snoopy was my
first love even before Batman so when J
and the wide shot Jay and his daughter
walk into the front of the building
quick stop building it always reminds me
of like Snoopy and Woodstock following
him walking you know to the house
walking wherever or something like that
we got Pearl Jam's daughter in this
flick which is kind of insane man
because you know they're very picky
about
putting music in movies and I put you
know I was cutting template of the movie
I put daughter in I fell in love with it
but I was like I know we'll never get it
and then omne was our music super I was
let me reach out and she reached out we
had the show than the scene and they
went for it man suddenly we had daughter
and we didn't have enough to pay a bunch
of money for when we did tusks we had to
pay a quarter of a million dollars for
the Fleetwood Mac song tusk just for the
song we didn't pay anything close to
that man for for using daughter in Jay
and Silent Bob reboot so I will always
be eternally grateful to the good folks
at Pearl Jam because man I couldn't
think like the whole movie is Big Time
Machine trip back to the 90s like at the
beginning of all the live shows I'd
always be like we've spent the better
part of the last year building a time
machine for you ladies of John then you
ready to go back to the [ __ ] nineties
with him in the always be like so it was
like a real nostalgic trip and whatnot
and for us to kind of come back and land
at quick stop in the present you know
[ __ ] at the end of the journey and
father and daughter having this
discussion and bonding and stuff like
that you know this this is everything to
me
Jay telling Millie the story of Jay and
Silent Bob's lives you know by way of
like we did this we did this since all
the things you've seemed to do in movies
Jay was like while we were on tour ears
like I just realized man we're making
that scene like Jay is talking to Millie
about what Jay and Silent Bob have done
but it's really Jamie telling Harley
about all the stuff that me and Kevin
Smith have done and stuff and I was like
yeah dude that's why I wrote it that way
you know glad you picked up on it I love
him to death he's my best friend in the
world man and he made this movie
absolutely made the two of them right
they're the absolute stars this picture
big old crane shot Ron gave me and that
is again not quick stop that's not New
Jersey that is Louisiana and we found a
building that kind of look like it Nate
skinned it to look almost exactly like
the quick stop there's and there's Brian
O'Halloran returning man and everything
comes full circle you know we have to
cut the pearl song write the program
song right there otherwise we have to
pay a lot more
comes ahead credit song but instead I
got MC Chris Dylan drinking blood smokin
40s and I always like to do the credits
where everyone cracks up man cuz I like
grew up watching Cannonball Run and [ __ ]
like that and Hooper and been smoking
abandoned they would always do that at
the end of their movies man my old man
[ __ ] love that this is very much like
Cannonball Run to some degree I mean as
much as a cross country journey intra
but my old man like I love everyone
loves bloopers but mo man we'd be
watching those movies and he would crack
the [ __ ] you know and it just made me
like want to be in the movie business
watching bloopers watching people laugh
like you know crack up on camera that's
how I got in the movie business I was
like oh my god that looks fun I want to
do that you know that looks like the
[ __ ] circus like you know aside from
what we see them do in the movies
playing when the credits run like you
could tell they were enjoying them
[ __ ] selves and stuff I want that so
I like to put them in the movies that I
do not all of them but like the bigger
comedies because comedies because
there's Jennifer because it's a callback
to that movies full [ __ ] callbacks
when I watch this movie I see a
completely different movie than everyone
else sees because I see the story of my
life like unfold and everyone you know
sees like a giant Samba movie but to me
it's like a big-ass scrapbook and stuff
like that so I love it
oh I love this movie it was so hard to
give it up when the tour was over and
you know when you have a box saw movie
at the box office normally like you're
lucky I'm lucky if you get like two
weeks at best
usually a weekend and stuff a month if
your end game or something like that oh
and then here's this there he is
the old man we love him to death
this was a little moment on the IMDB IMD
boat from our San Diego IMDB Comic Con
coverage and if we were I was telling
him you're gonna be in reboot man so
let's do a scene from it right now and I
included because him laughing is nothing
but joy for me man when people laugh you
see them foo they really are because
people present who they are in the world
and and you know laughter is an
involuntary thing that kind of lets you
drop all your defenses and you see look
at him look at the joy in his [ __ ]
face and stuff there's no I got making
Stan lamb he's cracking himself up he
thought this
was also [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] and he was
cracking up alona so I I loved it
especially because at the end he's just
like oh he don't talk but he goes get
the hell out of my scene and gippy J
perfect weight and it was thunderous
ladies and gentlemen every night of the
tour it was like when he came up and
then as soon as he made his Jay Joe and
we cut to the credit roll the audience
went absolutely nuts it was such a
beautiful time in my life I'll miss tour
in that movie Oh sad when it was all
over men but I'll get to do it again one
day they ever let us out with clerks
three I want to thank everyone that ever
went on that tour I know I did a lot of
talking about the tour if you feel like
oz wasn't the best commentary track
don't worry I'll probably do another one
or two one day you know we got podcasts
to do so these are just as easily that
but you know it's naturally I talk Traci
land and if you are ever making a movie
get Tracy Lynn Ron levy if you're ever
shooting a movie you need Ron Nate
[ __ ] killed our production design i
Kevin Smith what an editor he's barely
an editor that came as a gym battle he
crushed this score
Kevin Smith doesn't edit he just kind of
Harmon did our special effects I can't I
can't chat him and otherwise uh Robert
Kurtzman did iron Bob
Robert Kurtzman's at the dick and boogie
long and he did iron Bob Melissa did all
of our beautiful costumes and whatnot
Amin a has received in our score now I'm
just reading the [ __ ] on the screen oh
thank god the keys are done so I can
move on from that it was uh if you know
if you're lucky you get like a weekend
of the box office if your end game you
get a month maybe two months at the box
office where you know you're playing in
movie theaters we got to do it for four
[ __ ] months I got this pull that
taffy on the release of this mood for
four [ __ ] months man every night a
packed [ __ ] house it was absolute
bliss man I talked to the table in my
favor I didn't play the game the way
most people play the game but you don't
have to that's beauty of this world man
you figure out your own way into things
and you could do that you don't have to
do what everyone else does and do what
works for you we made a lot of money
with this tour and stuff and we wouldn't
have made a lot of money if we put it
out traditionally if we
like spent 1015 million 20 million
marketing the movie and hoped that
people showed up to the theaters men I
doubt we would have made our money back
when you put the [ __ ] marketing money
on top of the budget budget was eight
million marketing the movie would have
been let's let speak generous and say
[ __ ] twenty twenty eight million that
means you got to make 56 million at the
box office just to break even no I've
never made a movie made 56 mine taking
the movie out the way we did made so
much sense and I was able to pay the
back my equity investors at the end of
the tour man that's what we did with the
tour money it covered those cats Mona
so movie you know it is what you make of
it and for me I love look at the boys
the boy this this scene what [ __ ]
huge and every time every public
screening the kids returning from Jay
and Silent Bob strike back
if always my god they love them to death
and it made me regret not putting this
actual scene in the cut of the movie
it's just it didn't fit where it was
because it was right after Jay and
Harley split up and stuff and so I was
like well I could always put it in the
end credits if it doesn't work totally
but it's a boy the audience loved seeing
them again and right here Leah and
Karrueche crew cheese on Claus Leah now
the exact same name for like one year
was always like can you put me and
there's Chelsea who works in our office
and there's a great Robert Kirkman she
was like can you put me in mall rats no
because we're gonna make mall rats and
one day I was like you know she asked
like [ __ ] 200 days in a row is like
okay I'm gonna make that movie but then
we made this movie and so as I came in
you can make it down in New Orleans I'll
put you in there and stuff and it gets
in the end credits but proving if you
bug Kevin Smith enough they'll put you
in a movie and stuff there's been
referencing like you know Affleck was
the bomb and phantoms but with an update
of course for 2019 released the
snedecker the the the experience of Jay
and Silent Bob reboot man of not only
making it
with all my loved ones but then touring
it and meeting all the other loved ones
man the folks that came to see the movie
the folks that applauded for Jake and
Nick the two kids from the strike back
at night after night like they were
family and they were happy to see him
the folks who sold us out every stop of
the tour man thank you
he made that dream come true I dreamed
of this tour making the movie and then
taking it out to people who really dig
it and stuff and that's why I put all
your names and the credit see those
folks who came out for that see the long
list of names right there those are the
folks that played extras in the movie
generally you don't credit those folks
but like I was like as we put the
credits can we put all the names of all
the people that were at the chronicon
and it'll add another minute but like it
would be worth it cuz could you imagine
like one thing if you saw yourself on
screen but then you saw yourself in the
credits too like they did help us make
the movie man so it's me I was like
let's get him let's put him in there
yeah they didn't have lines so they
don't necessarily get credits but I was
like [ __ ] it let's do it and there
they all are so I see those names and
they sent me it's over there I can't
reach it but they gave me a book all
those people cards trading cards of all
the people that were extras all signed
with stuff on the back about their lives
and how much it meant for them being the
movie is so wonderful I got the best
[ __ ] followers in the world fans
whatever you want to call people who
like Kevin Smith stuff yeah there were
there's Emily is really my hair person
and stuff and all those people in that
scene are people that did win contests
and stuff that various stuff we've done
like the chocolate contest and the Hot
Topic contest this is from that sequence
that got cut Will Ferrell would have
been in this sequence as would a return
of Merkin but as we were shooting we
shot all this and then Jay and Silent
Bob were going to come over and kick
Kevin Smith the mill like you were in
Hollywood man it felt good to kick a
director let's go kick a bunch of that
how many people want to kick some ass
and then we would have went around
beating up famous directors a little PS
a little Marvel PSC or man that answers
an age-old [ __ ] question who put the
gum in the locks and clerks well who do
you [ __ ] think
Mickey skip bags thank you very much for
your help making the movie man
the good folks at legion em which many
of you may be legion and supporters
thank you the good folks at hideout man
our Tennessee folks thank you for that
Saban folks universal who had the movie
internationally men all these people
allowed me to like make this dippy movie
so thanks for that man okay
Wow we did it look at that man we've
been rolling for all this time and now
we're done let's see if why didn't you
take your tour to NYC we did we were
totally there I have my picture on the
missing children's board and Jay and
Silent Bob shrink back somebody said oh
my god I remember that that was so cool
I'm gonna go back and read the
commentary and you know when we put it
up and stuff over here but it was an
absolute joy ladies gentlemen hanging
out here tonight with you kill some time
for me
well we're all in quarantine and whatnot
the Facebook live version didn't pan out
but it looks like YouTube kinda I hope
this saves but the meantime I'm glad you
were here for it man listen for this on
the new episode of spawn cast which will
go up next week man in the meantime
thank you for listening to me blather on
about a movie I love so so dearly
remember folks weed helps everything
that's not what I was gonna say remember
folks you know your self-expression is
your self-expression and not everyone's
ever gonna [ __ ] agree with it or like
it and stuff but don't mean you don't
want to make it it's worth making even
if some people want to go go [ __ ]
yourselves like thank you and then you
just go right back into it and stuff
because at the end of the day feels good
to make things feels good to say things
even if they're don't be silly things
and [ __ ] thanks for hanging out my
friends
I'm gonna say goodbye to you and then
wrap up the podcast here
don't forget man chainsaw Bob reboot you
could watch it right now
on prime video iTunes YouTube Vudu
anywhere you can watch a movie streaming
and stuff Jane saw Bob reboot toys and
games sees two games
Jane saw a big fat card on game Jane saw
Bob smell my finger game you can find
those in our Amazon page there's a
badass a bunch of shirts the good folks
the Chive kyburi are making us stuff so
there's [ __ ] you can buy if you're into
that but you know the crisis going on so
maybe spend that money on tissues and
toilet paper and hand sanitizer and soap
and stuff like that but if you got money
left over after that there's all that
crap thanks for hanging out man thanks
for tolerating my commentary my
quarantine and Terry for Jay and Silent
Bob a reboot man you guys make it very
easy to be me thank you have a good
night folks
yeah I want to stop streaming